Les super-héros, c’est plutôt de gauche ou de droite ?
Ah oui, tu veux faire le jeu du clivage ?
Ouais.
Alors, des mecs qui se font auto-justice, c’est plutôt de droite.
Oui mais attend, la plupart, ils disent quand même que c’est pour défendre l’opprimé.
C’est plutôt éventuellement un truc de gauche.
De toutes façons, suivant les auteurs et les périodes,
ça change vachement les super-héros. Ils ont tous été pris en charge par plein d’auteurs différents.
Mais par contre, il y a un historien, William Blanc, qui a fait un livre sur la dimension politique des super-héros.
Je pense qu’on peut trouver des réponses...
Attends je t’arrête, est-ce que c’est pas un peu trop de nuances
pour le jeu du clivage quand même ?
Déjà, faut poser le contexte.
Les super-héros nous viennent des comics américains.
Bon alors déjà si c’est Américain, c’est quand même plutôt de droite, on va pas se mentir, y’a pas tellement de gauche aux États-Unis, non ?
Oui, c’est un peu de la mauvaise foi,
allons un peu plus dans les nuances.
A la base les comics, c’est publié par des petits éditeurs indépendants, en grande partie issus de l’immigration récente,
et c’est un produit plutôt bon marché, donc accessible aux catégories populaires, et ça c’est péte que c’est un peu plus de gauche.
Ensuite, au fur et à mesure ça se répand dans de nombreux médias,
pour aujourd’hui rapporter plusieurs milliards de dolls chaque année.
Donc, c’est de droite.
Ce grand succès des super-héros est en grande partie dû à la mythologie qui les entoure,
que William blanc qualifie de “sorte de ‘méta-mythe’
qui recoupe à la fois des légendes contemporaines,
de la mythologie plus ancienne, gréco-romaine ou encore arthurienne et des idéologies modernes en vogue aux États-Unis à ce moment-là.
Ainsi à leurs débuts, les super-héros sont l’incarnation d’une foi en un futur meilleur grâce au progrès, hérité du XIXe siècle
mais toujours contrebalancé cependant par la peur de voir le monde démocratique s’effondrer.
Ainsi, à la fin des années 30, les auteurs de comics, qui pour beaucoup viennent de milieux défavorisés,
utilisent les comics pour leurs revendications.
D’autant plus que ces médiums relèvent d’un art populaire méprisé par les élites
et adressé aux masses urbaines,
avec, dans les premières années une vraie liberté d’expressions.
Enfin jusqu’aux années 50, on va y revenir.
La plupart des éditeurs des premiers comics sont des enfants d’immigrés juifs venus d’Allemagne ou de Russie,
très présents dans les courants progressistes et révolutionnaires, dont beaucoup adhèrent aux partis de gauche aux USA et aux syndicats ouvriers.
Ce qui nous amène à parler de notre premier cas, probablement celui qui vient en premier à l’esprit lorsqu’on parle de super-héros,
Superman, évidemment.
J’vous ai entendu jouer au jeu du clivage ?
Ouais là, on est focus sur les super-héros,
enfin axés sur les super-héros.
Et du coup, Superman : de gauche ou de droite ?
- gauche.
- de droite !
Il a donc été créé en 1938 par deux jeunes auteurs juifs,
Joe Shuster et Jerry Siegel,
qui lui font endosser l’espoir d’un avenir meilleur au présent sombre de l’Occident,
en pleine crise économique et montée du fascisme.
Dans leur histoire, l’Amérique est une société en retard et c’est Superman,
en arrivant sur terre, qui va apporter un nouveau degré de civilisation.
Sauf que ça c’est un discours totalement à contre-courant de ce qui circule dans les médias dominants au milieu des années 30.
Les strips diffusés dans la grande presse montrent alors plutôt des personnages sudistes,
symbole du colonialisme,
qui apportent leur marque civilisatrice sur d’autres planètes extra-terrestres, tels Buck Rogers ou Flash Gordon.
Ce n’est donc pas anodin de présenter le pays comme relativement retardé et ayant besoin d’évoluer
plutôt que comme celui qui apporte la civilisation ailleurs.
Les auteurs soulignent dans leurs histoire la montée inquiétante des militarismes
et Superman, surnommé l’homme de demain,
est l’espoir d’un monde sans guerre.
Sa première livraison raconte une histoire où il impose une trêve entre deux dictateurs se faisant la guerre,
poussés par un vendeur d’armes de Washington.
En février 1940, dans les pages du magazine Look,
il recommence mais avec Hitler et Staline.
Donc, il est au centre quoi.
Non, ça c’est pas les règles ça déjà. Le centre, ça existe pas, dans le jeu du clivage, en fait.
Cette utopie d’un pacificateur de l’ordre international est régulière chez lui,
comme lorsqu’il détruit l’arsenal nucléaire soviétique et américain dans le film Superman IV, The Quest for Peace de 1987.
Cela dit, et sans surprise, sa figure évolue en fonction des auteurs, oui logique,
mais aussi du contexte géopolitique.
Lorsque la guerre froide est terminée, on lui fait aussi incarner les errements des États-Unis,
devenue la seule puissance mondiale mais se heurtant pourtant à ses limites.
En janvier 1999, Paul Dini et Alex Ross, dans leur album
"Superman: Peace on Earth",
représentent le super-héros luttant contre la faim dans le monde
en apportant lui-même de la nourriture aux nécessiteux, à l’image du messianisme américain.
Mais finalement cette action provoque plus de problèmes qu’elle n’en résout
et Superman comprend que sa mission est vouée à l’échec.
Il reprend alors modestement son identité de Clark Kent pour se contenter d’enseigner à des enfants qui viennent visiter la ferme de ses parents
comment cultiver des plantes.
L’homme du futur des années 30 s’est pris dans la gueule le no future des années 70,
pour une prise de conscience de ses limites,
à l’image des États-Unis désabusés,
suite à l’échec des interventions américaines en Bosnie, Somalie et Irak.
Après le 11 septembre, Alex Ross peint carrément le super-héros de dos,
levant les yeux vers une affiche beaucoup plus grande que lui,
représentant les victimes des attentats et les secouristes;
et lâchant un pauvre petit “wow”
devant les héros ordinaires qui trime dans l’actualité sombre que la superpuissance américaine n’a pas pu empêcher.
Alors Superman, c’est de droite ou de gauche ?
Dites voir, ça joue au jeu du clivage sans moi par ici ?
C’est pas très sympa ça, surtout que j’ai un petit niveau.
Y a une thématique ?
Les super-héros, genre Batman.
De droite.
- T'as pas hésité hein ?
- En même temps, c'est facile.
C’est pas si tranché.
Oui, c’est un riche héritier qui par exemple dans le film de Nolan de 2012, "The Dark Knight Rises",
combat entre autre une coalition du sous-prolétariat de la ville
qui veut détruire l’ordre social,
ou bien sûr, avec le film "Joker" de 2019,
qui fait de son pire ennemi, le leader des opprimés, malgré lui, certes,
mais néanmoins, Batman c’est LE super-héros de droite.
Dès sa création dans le "Detective Comics" n°27 de mai 39,
Bob Kane et Bill Finger en ont fait l’expression des craintes associées au prolétariat.
C’est typiquement un personnage relevant du stéréotype des gentlemen issus de l’élite
très en vogue dans les polars du XIXe siècle,
se réclamant d’un style de nouveaux chevaliers maintenant l’ordre.
D’ailleurs c’est son surnom, le Dark Knight, depuis le n°1 du comics Batman, en 1940.
C’est aussi un personnage assez libertarien, au-dessus de la loi car celle-ci est corrompue à Gotham,
souvent pourchassé par la police, mais il collabore aussi régulièrement avec elle,
comme avec le commissaire Gordon.
Bref, tout ça c’est peut-être plutôt de drouate, MAIS
Batman, c’est aussi Robin,
et on peut introduire une nuance
un poil progressiste dans le personnage, même si c’est un tout petit poil.
Evidemment, beaucoup de gens voient dans la relation de Batman et Robin un sous-texte homoérotique,
en particulier dans les années 40-50.
C’est vrai que les surhumains des comics
ne sont pas sans évoquer l’esthétique camp et l’imagerie des milieux gays, avec des costumes vifs,
colorés, moulants, à l’opposé des normes vestimentaires masculines des années 50-60.
Le fait de se déguiser et de se masquer peut aussi évoquer l’obligation pour les homosexuels de cette époque de cacher leur orientation sexuelle.
Bien sûr, ceci n’est jamais explicite mais a pu être lu ainsi par une catégorie de la population en quête de son identité sexuelle.
Ce que tout le monde ne voit pas d’un bon œil d’ailleurs.
Le psychiatre Fredric Wertham qui n’aime vraiment pas du tout les comics
et considère qu’ils pervertissent la jeunesse
publie le livre "The Seduction of The Innocent" en 1954,
où l’on peut lire, je cite :
“Seule une personne méconnaissant les fondements de la psychiatrie et de la psychopathologie sexuelle
peut ignorer la subtile atmosphère homoérotique qui imprègne les aventures d’un Batman mature
et de son jeune ami Robin [...].
Parfois, Batman se retrouve au lit, blessé,
et le jeune Robin est représenté assis à côté de lui.
Ils vivent une vie idyllique chez eux.”
OULALA.
Eh bien,
figurez-vous que la parole de ce monsieur a eu bcp de poids,
en plus dans un contexte
où la peur du communisme aux États-Unis se double d’une obsession homophobe
qui met dans un gros panier à salade le militantisme de gauche, l’athéisme et les pratiques sexuelles qualifiées d’anormales,
QUI VONT ANEANTIR LES FONDEMENTS DE LA FAMILLE ET DONC LA SOCIETE AMÉRICAINE !
Et ça a tellement d’écho
qu’on adopte le Comics Code Authority.
Ce dernier impose une censure aux auteurs qui doivent bannir les “relations sexuelles illicites”
et les “anormalités sexuelles” de leurs récits.
Alors vite vite, il faut donner à Superman ou à Batman un semblant de foyer dans la norme.
En 1955, ils se retrouvent tous les deux avec un chien
(la norme, OK)
et en 1956 arrive dans Detective Comics n°233,
Batwoman, une partenaire platonique pour Bruce Wayne.
Ce mouvement d’auto-censure a marqué des générations d’auteurs, qui en ont parlé plus tard à travers leurs créations.
Attention, je vais vous décrire une scène violente, si vous n’avez pas envie de l’entendre, allez directement à ce timecode !
Dans l’univers de la série Watchmen, en 86-87,
Alan Moore dépeint la disparition de certains super-héros dans les années 50 en raison de leur homosexualité.
Deux d’entre eux meurent dans des circonstances troubles, notamment Silhouette, accusée d’être homosexuelle.
Lorsque Zack Snyder adapte au cinéma le comics d’Alan Moore,
il décrit aussi cette homophobie virulente des États-Unis d’après-guerre.
Silhouette y est assassinée dans son lit avec son amante, alors que le mot “putes lesbiennes” a été tracé sur le mur avec leur sang.
Oui, car heureusement le Comics Code a fini par être contourné, puis par tomber en désuétude.
Malgré quelques tâtonnements dans les underground comix, les années 80 pour que l’homosexualité soit enfin évoquée,
alors que le militantisme LGBTQI+ se fait connaître du grand public.
C’est d’abord destiné à un public averti, exclusivement dans des boutiques spécialisées.
On peut citer le roman graphique Camelot 3000 de Mike Barr et Brian Bolland,
édité entre 82 et 85.
On y voit les chevaliers de la table ronde se réincarner dans le futur
et dans des corps différents de leurs précédents.
Notamment Tristan devient une femme qui s’impose dans un groupe de guerrier et se bat avec eux.
Elle retrouve son amour médiéval Iseult, aussi réincarnée en femme et, après une longue hésitation,
elles entament une relation explicitement représentée dans le n°12, en avril 1985.
Ceci ouvre la voie aux héroïnes lesbiennes, d’abord chez les éditeurs indépendants.
C’est le cas de l’héroïne Sarah Rainmaker, de l’équipe Gen, dont les lectrices découvrent l’homosexualité dans le comics
Gen 13 n°2 de mai 1995.
Les grands éditeurs suivent ensuite et modifient certaines de leurs super-héroïnes pour en faire des personnages ouvertement gay.
C’est dans le comics 52 n°7 de juin 2006 que l’homosexualité de Batwoman est révélée,
elle qui avait été à la base créée pour donner à Batman un semblant de relation hétéro.
Elle devient alors le porte-parole de la communauté lesbienne
et son succès est assuré puisqu’elle est dotée de sa propre série de comics à partir de septembre 2011.
Les super-héros masculins gays ne sont pas en reste.
Comme on l’a vu, dans un premier temps ce n’est pas explicite,
pour être de plus en plus assumé.
Il y a plusieurs exemples, mais je vous cite celui-ci : Jean-Paul Beaubier, alias Northstar (Vega en français),
super-héros québécois, membre de la Division Alpha,
et c’est un personnage qui illustre bien les stratégies utilisées dans les années 80 pour créer des super-héros gay sans l’affirmer ouvertement.
Le scénariste John Byrne,
Birne, je ne sais pas,
dès les premiers numéro d’Alpha Flight à partir d’août 1983,
chez Marvel, laisse des indices de son orientation sexuelle.
Il dira ensuite en interview qu’il avait pensé qu’il était temps qu'un personnage gay voit le jour
mais que le contexte ne permettait pas encore le faire de manière franche.
Lorsque Bill Mantlo reprend  Alpha Flight à partir de décembre 85,
il va beaucoup plus loin dans les allusions, par exemple, au n°42 de janvier 87,
le super-héros contracte une mystérieuse maladie qui évoque le SIDA et dont il peine à se débarrasser.
Enfin, au numéro 106 de mars 1992, Northstar peut enfin affirmer son homosexualité.
Le numéro connaît un tel succès qu’il est réimprimé, alors qu’à la même époque, des auteurs de comics affirment publiquement leur homosexualité, tel Philip Craig Russel en 1991.
Enfin Northstar rejoint les X-men, et il se marie à un de ses compagnons au n°51 d’Astonishing X-Men, en septembre 2012,
alors que le débat sur le mariage gay fait rage aux États-Unis.
Bref, aujourd’hui, on trouve un nombre de super-héros gays dans les comics,
pour plaire à un public plus jeune et sensible à ces questions.
On a atteint un nouveau cran alors qu’ils arrivent aussi dans les séries télévisées,
mais le cinéma, le médium le plus populaire et le plus lucratif du genre, est encore assez à la traîne.
Et bien sûr, on n’a parlé ici que de personnages homosexuels, mais on a encore beaucoup à faire pour la diversité.
Les personnages non-binaires par exemple ne commencent qu’à peine à être évoqués dans les comics,
telle Lord Fanny.
On était partis d’où comme ça ?
Ah oui, Batman.
Bon alors du coup, Batman, c’est de droite ou de gauche ?
Batman serait de drôche,
elle est quand même dure à avaler celle là.
Alors que Wonder Woman…
Alors Wonder Woman en fait, ça dépend.
Bah, une meuf qui fout des raclées aux méchants, c’est pas censé être de gauche ça ?
La petite tenue pour exciter les mecs, ça c’est de gauche ça peut-être.
Il vaut mieux répondre de drôche, comme pour Batman.
Non mais tu peux pas dire ça. Batman et Wonder Woman, c’est pas pareil.
C’est pas si tranché ça non plus.
Elle n’est pas la toute première super-héroïne lorsqu’elle est créée dans le n°8
de All Star Comics, en décembre 1941
mais elle s’impose très rapidement.
Son créateur est le docteur en psychologie William Moulton Marston,
qui s’est convaincu au cours de ses recherches que l’avenir connaîtrait l’imposition du matriarcat américain.
Il dit en février 1942 : « Le futur appartient à la femme […] ; les femmes dirigeront le monde. »
Il utilise alors les comics pour diffuser ses théories.
Comme pour Superman, on retrouve un personnage qui vient d’une civilisation plus avancée,
qui va faire progresser l’Amérique.
Cette civilisation, elle vient de Paradise Island à la technologie très avancée,
en français Themyscira, tiré de Thémiscyre qui est dans la mythologie la capitale des Amazones,
justement le peuple de Wonder Woman.
Marston a conçu son personnage à l’opposé des actions des hommes
commandées par leurs pulsions de domination et de destruction.
Les hommes qu’elle affronte sont des malades qu’elle veut soigner, même par la force.
Les hommes qu’elle affronte sont des malades qu’elle veut soigner, même par la force. Wonder Woman enferme ses adversaires dans l’île de la Réhabilitation pour modifier leur comportement violent
et les réintégrer plus tard dans la société.
Marston dépeint donc sa vision d’une force féminine bienveillante pour une utopie matriarcale du turfu.
BON. La femme guerrière et forte qui combat des hommes par la force,
c’est plutôt de gauche
MAIS la vision de la femme qui veut les soigner et qui est dans le care, c’est encore une répartition traditionnelle des rôles.
MAIS BON c’est les années 40, c’est déjà un énorme truc de proposer
une fiction avec une société matriarcale plus avancée que l’Amérique.
Ça s’inscrit d’ailleurs dans un contexte d’évolution des mentalités.
Peu après l’entrée en guerre des États-Unis, les femmes ont leur propre ligue de baseball professionnelle
pour compenser le manque de joueurs masculins,
elles occupent des postes qui étaient réservés aux hommes partis au front,
même si elles ne combattent pas elles-mêmes.
Marston soutient ce mouvement et fait même dire à Wonder Woman «Rejoins les WAAC et les WAVES et bats-toi pour ton pays. ! »,
c’est la période de la fameuse affiche We Can Do It de J. Howard Miller, en 1942.
Qui plus est, à partir du n°2 de Sensation Comics, en février 42, Wonder Woman est accompagnée par les Holiday Girls
qui ne sont pas du tout à l’image des autres représentations féminines typiques des comics, beaucoup plus de l’ordre des pin-ups,
elles ont des physiques variés et vont à l’université.
Wonder Woman elle-même, dans les premières années, n’a pas le physique pulpeux propre à assouvir les fantasmes masculins.
Cela dit, y’a quand même une contradiction dans le fait d’affirmer qu’elle n’est pas faite pour être un fantasme masculin
puisqu’il y a quand même UN MAX DE SCÈNE DE BONDAGE.
Beaucoup de gens y ont lu l’expression des kinks sexuels de l’auteur.
William Blanc tempère un peu en disant que déjà la symbolique médiévale avec les chaînes etc.,
c’est très présent d’une manière générale dans les comics,
ensuite c’est souvent dans Wonder Woman les hommes qui sont attachés
et qui sont libérés par elle, donc on a plutôt une inversion du cliché.
Il explique que Marston et son entourage baignent aussi dans une culture féministe
où on voit souvent utilisée la symbolique de la femme qui se libère des chaînes de la domination masculine dans les affiches etc.,
donc ça a pu être une référence graphique pour eux.
Notamment le dessinateur de la plupart des aventures de Wonder Woman dans les années 40,
Harry G Peter, avait déjà illustré dans les années 1910
"The Modern Woman", un journal soutenant les suffragistes américaines militant pour le droit de vote des femmes.
Il était aussi proche de l’illustratrice Lou Rogers
qui avait fait dessin de 1912, qui s’appelait "Tearing off the Bonds",
représentant une allégorie féministe se défaisant des liens du sexisme.
Peters s’est inspiré de ce dessin pour représenter la Wonder Woman qu’il dessine en 1943,
arrachant les chaînes de la « domination masculine », des « discriminations » et du « puritanisme ».
Les chaînes c’est un motif qu’on retrouve aussi dans une rubrique intitulée « Les Wonder Women de l'Histoire »,
supervisée par Alice Marble, championne de tennis
et qui présente des portraits de femmes qui ont lutté pour la cause féminine.
Du coup, les chaînes dans Wonder Woman, le fait qu’elle attache des hommes etc.,
c’est peut-être pas juste une expression du kink de l’auteur.
Mais aussi une façon d’illustrer ce que Marston appelle
«l’autorité bienveillante des femmes ».
Ah oui, donc on est de retour dans le care.
Oui, totalement, mais cela dit pour l’époque, c’est les années 40, c’est déjà un truc.
Et si tu regardes au dela d’une hormone en elle même, si tu regardes qui l’a écrite,
là c’est un peu punk quoi.
Marston, à l’époque, il était en trouple avec deux femmes qui étaient super-féministes.
Elles ont forcément un peu influencé son écriture,
sa façon de créer le personnage.
Lui il vivait vraiment à l’encontre de toutes les normes de société de l’époque.
La vision de la famille, lui, c’était pas la même chose.
Il le vivait bien même si les universités pour lesquelles il a travaillé ne voyait pas ça d’un bon œil.
Il s’est fait pas mal virer des universités.
Après, il a fait des tas de trucs, il a inventé
le détecteur de mensonges.
OK !
Il travaillait beaucoup sur les émotions et sur le sexe féminin,
et la sexualité des femmes, la sexualité des hommes, etc.
Et ça transparait dans l’œuvre, évidemment.
C’est un peu de gauche engagée quoi.
Mais après, par contre, quand il est mort, ça a tout changé.
Parce que celle qui était sa femme officielle, mariée avec lui,
elle est allé voir l’éditeur pour reprendre le flambeau, pour continuer à écrire les épisodes.
Et là, on lui a dit : “Non, Madame, rentrez chez vous.”
En effet, à sa mort en 47, tout ça, ça a été bien mis à mal.
Avec la nouvelle équipe créative, Wonder Woman devient déjà beaucoup plus érotisée.
Son nouvel auteur, Robert Kanigher en fait une femme beaucoup plus traditionnelle,
qui devient successivement top-model ou baby-sitter.
Les Holidays Girls, quant à elles, disparaissent progressivement,
tout comme la rubrique “Wonder Woman of History”, remplacée par des bandes dessinées romantiques avec des héroïnes qui cherchent l’amour.
Mais c’est le coup de grâce avec la publication du psychiatre Fredric Wertham dont on a déjà parlée.
A ses yeux Wonder Woman est “l’équivalent lesbien de Batman”,
les femmes qui ne construisent pas de foyer et n’ont pas de famille, ni d’amour maternel,
ça va pas du tout.
Quitte à se contredire parce que lorsque Wonder Woman adopte une fille,
il interprète ça au contraire comme des aspects lesbiens.
Le Comics Code finit d’enfoncer le clou en exigeant que les publications mettent l'accent sur la valeur du foyer
et sur le caractère sacré du mariage.
Et les images relevant de la « perversité » sont interdites.
Ça porte un bon coup à WW, mais elle revient en force à la fin des années 60,
avec la seconde vague féministe et la période de la libération sexuelle
pour devenir une égérie émancipatrice.
On va la trouver luttant contre les violences conjugales, comme dans la série "Wonder Woman: Once and Future Story" en 98,
dessinée par Colleen Doran, et scénarisée par Trina Robbins,
une pionnière des comics underground féministes des années 70
qui a été la 1ere femme à officiellement dessiner les aventures de l'héroïne en 1986.
Dans les années 2000, le personnage évolue avec les revendications féministes.
Elle se tourne vers de nouveaux sujets comme la condition des femmes du tiers-monde.
Et le personnage peut aussi faire l’objet de la critique des féministes.
Par exemple, en octobre 2016, les Nations-Unies choisissent Wonder Woman comme symbole d’une campagne mondiale pour l’égalité des sexes,
ce qui suscite un tollé et une pétition puisque, à l’inverse de la façon dont son créateur l’avait pensée,
Wonder Woman est trop devenue une femme aux proportions inhumaines, en tenue sexy et aux couleurs de l’Amérique,
à tel point que l’ONU retire sa campagne !
Et oui, on n’est plus à l’époque de Marston où on pensait que les États-Unis apporteraient un futur radieux.
D’ailleurs, le film de 2017 dépeint une Wonder Woman tuant et détruisant ceux qu’elle considère comme ses ennemis,
belle allégorie de l’interventionnisme agressif américain.
Du coup, Wonder Woman, elle est de gauche ou de droite.
Bon y aurait encore énormément de chose à dire ou de super-héros à traiter pour parler de politique et comics,
évidemment Captain América, qui fout une torgnole à Hitler dans sa première apparition en 1941
ou Black Panther, le premier super-héros africain, créé en 66,
et encore bien d’autres choses, bref, si vous voulez en savoir plus je vous recommande évidemment la lecture de l’ouvrage de William Blanc qui traite de ça aussi…
En tout cas, dans le fond, on voit bien que ça dépend des auteurs et des périodes, évidemment.
En plus, vous avez bien compris qu’on fait de la mauvaise foi assumée avec nos propres critères 100% subjectifs de ce que c’est la droite et la gauche
C’EST POUR LA VANNE, DÉTENDEZ-VOUS DANS LES COM.
C’est la fin de cette vidéo, j’espère qu’elle vous a plu.
Vous pouvez rajouter en commentaire des idées de super-héros ou de super-héroïne avec des dimensions politiques.
N’hésitez pas, on en discute. D’ailleurs, si vous voulez en discuter, on peut aussi se retrouver sur le Discord du Vortex.
Après nos épisodes, on peut débriefer ensemble.
Et puis bien sûr, si ce n’est pas encore fait, abonnez-vous pour ne rater aucune vidéo même si celle-ci était la meilleure, je sais.
Mais je vous promet, il y en aura plein d’autres des super bien.
Et moi je vous dis, à la prochaine.
Bah, c’est bien une conclusion de droite.
C’est bien une phrase de gauche ça.
Et du coup la poutre, de gauche ou de droite ?
Ah la poutre, c’est carré, c’est droit, c’est rigide,...
merde, c'est de droite.